I would go on there mining welcome thank
you some more fine I'm back I don't know
if this is the first video that goes
happen it's good to be back Russ I've
been missing you
where have you been I've been making
many you haven't daenam six days the
fires map has got a great description kg
good skipper whatever all right well I
got a jet pack instead of that stupid
bye i bob has luggage my penis
extinguished
I got a black penis finally my dreams
come true yeah I can fly with my black
penis ah that didn't work out all right
black penis - I've been charged black
penis no black minutes come down come
down black penis I'm not racist funny
black Vedas you killed me
oh that's somebody quotable hey let's go
black penis judge black Vedas very good
grades last James Bond's black bean I
love every Chinese and every black and
white and dinosaurs and everything I
like joke I'm sorry it's that offends
you okay
kill your boss Santa Claus is sicker who
is Santa Claus boss anyway alright
you're late
yeah fired get um
all right I'm hot [ __ ] ha ha what what
it's gonna kiss the ground
mwah mwah yeah all right they're coming
meatball power did what it's coming up I
am I still finished with the meatball
power
hey what about scratch my back with a
mortal minute I don't think Santa is a
good game ok
Segway guy not a matte white beard
that's how I roll that's how I get it
all right
shut up I have a guy wake up Oh buck
stars all right hey how're you then all
right come I just need some speed here
what yeah what sorry about your foot man
all right there we go now that was your
penis all right out of here but well
stop standing in the way don't [ __ ] with
me there we go there we go
don't whoa where are you going
I want to go at adventure out and I kill
this thing you still alive ha ha fives
for pride too I give you a four I [ __ ]
oh I love walking characters all right
write + Z to begin like this and walk
with wha what what what what am i doing
Hey what get down tonight
ain't no pot like a PewDiePie party oh
yeah
it's how I roll into the club separate
ladies anyone want some of the pit pack
[ __ ] yeah this is a small step for me
all right
[Music]
I got [ __ ] merica happy wheels for
years you can be a million people asking
about that song all right it's the best
youtuber no one gives a [ __ ]
all right Santa I saw their eye I got
started I got a new hat
[Music]
vivacious [ __ ] yeah what and satisfied
made it before me son of a [ __ ] log
runs no I haven't seen none of that
all right go go whoa [ __ ] that a poo is
raining boots it was me shut up you can
make a proper poop I just going on here
I'm carving a bicycle I have no feet but
they don't have a meters how then would
it make it it's amazing
let's try to make it properly all right
Go Fish
so goddammit I stick stop sucking your
own penis by said again no try [ __ ]
harder gotta try [ __ ] harder you say
that [ __ ] by need more speed front flap
you say that no I said you say your name
kill him three that sounds fantastic
don't move until you're in the air once
you are in the air pop but why they do
that I am
I like this really wig and let's do that
again
go for it all right
thank gosh I'm awful at this come on
what you can do grab it and that's
injected gosh Hey
not sure what the [ __ ] happened tonight
okay let's go
angry human Birds this is one of those
[ __ ] that oh wait yeah I know I'm a
little better still alive I'm coming for
you [ __ ] you now [ __ ] rape you come
here come here come here come here come
on here we go
god I don't know what I just that much
fat higher get down the betcha why do
you still survive
hey champ I hate you so much hey [ __ ] it
all I didn't live that's Pleasant Temple
Run well look at does boss
hey hey hey Maya no I lost my leg hey
I'm still collecting coins that's
awesome
I don't even have to play nice okay what
is that thing anyway
wait what if I do this take me sorry all
right yeah let's go to Narnia [ __ ] yet
all that I connecting and get collecting
it ah [ __ ] yeah I got it cut [ __ ] yeah
you like it yeah
wait you're so beautiful buddy whoa
front flip oh my god oh my god this is
amazing I'm kissing your genitals now
aren't I all right
come on get back on your feet okay ah
[ __ ]
all right let's played properly there we
go Chuck what Chuck punch
flip I'm not supposed to jump that I'm
yep there we go donate that thing catch
up on me ah you saw that [ __ ] I was on
that alright what am i doing you try
shag [ __ ] vegetable
alright here we go again I almost now
when I jump I [ __ ] new keyboard I
don't know where they're [ __ ]
clicking you say that [ __ ] that's how I
roll
that's how I get all the ladies here we
go
not even a private stop at [ __ ] well it
was finished there anyway that was the
last one you got me good mr. mess if I
doesn't even want me anymore a mean
world that is fantastic
nah hey hey that's it's blinking wait
for screen no go now go
and Duncan challenge okay all right dad
watch your head
and that was thanks all right area
every now and tell me at it
I bike take me hey yeah I can't talk
today I'm so [ __ ] tired alright here
we go
what there we go
Tama all right that's gonna be me in a
couple of seconds [ __ ] alright press
space while on the platform alright I
love me back so gay
what are you [ __ ] kidding me no I get
the feeling I wanted to see that one
though alright oh no I [ __ ] I hope your
lips reach petabyte doesn't want you and
you alright I got it right ah okay don't
you realize how disgusting that it I go
left to laughter that's Georgia guys
sing Beyonce shut up god damn you're so
gay
God what why you did it
[ __ ] yeah take your time to read this
touch it
alright that was a pretty cool nap
Lamborghini legette demo it's legit whoa
I got a Lamborghini that's it Wow what
let me get comfortable as I can ride
this there we go with my face of course
what you drive with your arms is so 2010
I Drive inside with my face that's got
my body students in white turn front
flap double front flip trap or live
Virginia front flipper almost alright
that's it for me today Bruce but lack
babies you enjoyed subscribe come
Tuesday and I'll see you next episode of
whatever I make this is good to be back
Russ I'm a little tired and it's [ __ ]
hot today I'm sorry for this episode
suck I don't [ __ ] know no no no no
we're not JB Oh No shut up back back
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] your ball stop
bang yes I'm gay anyways watch what the
[ __ ]